monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre madamees et
Messieurs les rapporteurs monsieur le
président de la commission des lois mes
chers
collègues au même titre que le reste du
continent notre pays fait face
aujourd'hui à un afflux migratoire
majeur nos partenaires européens ont
pris diverses mesures pour y faire
face Finlande a fermé sa frontière russe
le Danemark a envisagé de renvoyer ses
migrants au
Rwanda il faut dire que la Turquie la
Biélorussie la Russie n'hésit pas à
employer les flux migratoires comme arme
géopolitique contre
l'Europe nos concitoyens sont 71 % à
considérer que l'immigration est trop
importante en France dans ces conditions
nous devions légiférer
il fallait mettre un terme au
détournement manifeste de notre droit
comme l'a rappelé le président de la
commission des lois mettre en œuvre une
immigration choisie sur la base de
quotas et reconduire à la frontière ceux
qui n'ont pas leur place dans notre pays
nous nous réjouissons groupe des
indépendants que la commission mixte
paritaire soit parvenue à un
accord l'équilibre général du texte issu
du Sénat a été
respecté il oriente notre pays
imigration
choisie le Parlement a fait ce choix en
précisant d'abord ce qu'il voulait un
flux d'immigration mieux contrôlé
notamment à travers l'instauration de
cot le texte sur lequel nous allons
voter rappelle également un principe
fondamental le communautarisme n pas sa
place dans notre pays la finalité de
l'immigration est l'intégration
comme cela a été rappelé par Madame la
rapporteur les deux clés les deux clés
d'une intégration réussie sont la
maîtrise de la langue de la langue
française et le
travail la régularisation des étrangers
qui sont employés dans les métiers en
tenstion traduit notre attachement à la
valeur travail il est important de
sortir ces personnes de toute
vulnérabilité tout en évitant tout appel
d'air cette mesure ne doit pas nous
êcher de réfléchir aux causes profondes
de la pénurie de main d'œvre dans
certains secteurs qui est évidente et
d'y apporter des solutions le texte de
la CMP dit également ce que nous ne
voulons pas les étrangers ne respectant
pas nos lois nos droits nos devoirs
essentiels et nos valeurs ne doivent pas
pouvoir rester dans notre pays de trop
nombreuses disposition empêchaient le
réloignement tandis que les des délits
et des crimes continuaient d'être commis
par ces mêmes personnes nos concitoyens
ne peuvent plus l'accepter et il était
grand temps d'y
remédier la maîtrise des flux
migratoires ne pourra toutefois être
tout à fait efficace qu'à la condition
d'être accompagné de règles européennes
efficaces la liberté de circulation au
sein de l'espace Schengen implique
nécessairement un contrôle strict aux
frontières de
l'Union l'ensemble des citoyens de
l'Union européenne nourrissent de fortes
attentes dans l'obtique de l'adoption
prochaine du pacte asile et
migration l'Union européenne doit elle
aussi faire preuve de son efficacité et
ne pas prêter le flan aux critiques
comme tous les Européens nos concitoyens
ne peuvent plus accepter une immigration
subie la politique doit relever le défi
migratoire avec justice et fermeté sans
attendre nouveau paquet législatif
européen le groupe Les Indépendants
votera en faveur de l'adoption de ce
texte merci la parole est
à